so i was like oh okay um where's the
mouthwash
[Music]
stop do you notice it do you see it now
do you see it no no whenever it's a
blessing
[Music]
okay today's topic um abba and preach
these guys are [ __ ] idiots andrew
tate is banned censorship will backfire
no it won't oh my god dude again more
men telling women now i didn't did
anyone actually watch this ad and preach
[ __ ]
so you call this [ __ ] idiots for a
video you didn't even watch
and you didn't even
this is so on par for ethan and his
stupid-ass friends i've been preached by
the way i've never really talked about
them but they made a video defending
[ __ ] friction
fresh and fit yeah they have a lot of
bad takes
yeah it sucks i've watched a few of
their videos like earlier this year and
i thought they were hilarious me too but
then like yeah deeper dive it's like
[ __ ] i actually had the same opinion and
i was really surprised when they're like
yo fresh and fit
there's no evidence to accuse them
picking coconuts from barbados but it's
just a woman's account so like he's
talking about it oh my god
this man gotta be one of the slimiest
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
he's actually sitting there trying to
make her sound like freshman fit
defenders
bruh not even their fan base would echo
what the [ __ ] you're saying right now
that's how goddamn brain you think we
are what
what
how
this dumb [ __ ] said what i just
want to point out i was abba's trigger
game is so good that he's triggering his
own self i didn't do [ __ ] he's triggered
right now
it's game have you not done a simple
google search [ __ ]
not not one not one listen we've done
enough videos clowning these dumb people
okay god you're just them aside
we do one video in their favor not
because all of a sudden we turn the leaf
you won't know why we did it because
ethan what you did was so goddamn
[ __ ] stupid you brought on some young
teenager to come tell salicious lies
about another man just because you
dislike them so much you're willing to
allow someone come on tell disparaging
lies just to get back at them you lack
so much character that you bring on a
[ __ ] liar try to encourage her to say
that she was somehow like
a bad this is very bad
i think he may have assaulted you i mean
at this point i
yeah i mean i don't want to say that but
like again like
i don't want to say that but that's
someone i'm going to let you make your
assumption right
just because you hate somebody that's
how twisted you are in your head and you
got the audacity to call us defenders no
it's not that we're defenders you're
just so [ __ ] unethical
that we saw that [ __ ] we said damn
we gotta defend these [ __ ]
and then i go to the bathroom like in
the kitchen he's like that's not where
the mouthwash is so i was like oh okay
um where's the mouthwash
[Music]
[Music]
we didn't defend them we defend the
principle of it which is you brought up
somebody who came to tell on some lies
about somebody to disparage their
reputation okay and ethan you might wish
that somebody did the same for you
because i remember very recently you
were in some kind of little scandal
where people were claiming that you guys
were mistreating your employees and left
a bunch of reviews and you said these
are all false these are all false well
guess what guess what
why don't we believe the people who
claim that you did something wrong you
want to know why because we require
evidence proof that people are telling
the truth when they want to disparage
somebody you think i would decide to go
interview those people and try to have
them send me stories so i could take you
down because i just like you of course i
wouldn't do that why because that's
unethical and i hope one day when you
get caught in a much bigger scandal
because it will happen all right
somebody will make up something about
you or maybe it's true i don't know i
hope that people don't just jump on that
bandwagon because they dislike you i
hope someone actually takes the time to
have the evidence there's one thing to
dislike these guys criticize them do
whatever you want and that's what we do
you brought up somebody who came to tell
a bunch of [ __ ] lives with a
nonsensical story very and then
encouraged her to make the crime sound
worse than what it actually was just
because you hate them that's you
verifiable very verifiable rough
talk about i'm lost [ __ ] five minute
walk away from her place
[Laughter]
[ __ ] google map that should you win
downtown
five minute walk from your place talk
about i'm stranded get the [ __ ] out of
here bro
wow you no they googled it
you you triggered your own self
i guess but
he's really a gooper he got so much to
say the [ __ ] didn't watch the
video he didn't even watch a video he
didn't have it made no research no
google search nothing right and then
you're gonna say you're gonna you that's
really the audacity calling us you're
gonna tell me that we
we
are fresh and fit defenders
[ __ ] are you high or [ __ ]
you can't use that word anymore are you
high
you can use that word
or [ __ ]
or late
they're doing the brave
act the defiant act of defending andrew
tayet
such bravery what is the psychological
thing going here because all these guys
are like
i don't agree with him but
it's like
they're what they want to be they want
to present themselves as like the
enlightened free speech warrior yeah
yeah a lot of people you know have
strong opinions about free speech and
discord and what uh discourse and what
should be allowed and but i don't think
they care dan i think they
just care about their perception because
if you cared about free speech you would
understand
that has nothing to do with youtube in
the first place oh my god our video
wasn't about free speech oh my yeah but
when you don't watch it you don't know
that the video had nothing to do with
research jesus christ man
free speech i don't even think was
mentioned a single time in the video the
laziness the video was about addressing
the issues that men deal with that are
being unaddressed in society leading to
people like andrew tate that's why we
said it would backfire because another
guy like him will come along who's much
bigger much worse okay that's why we
said that my god but of course when you
come on these platforms and give dumb
takes on videos you didn't even watch
you can afford to say stupid [ __ ] about
free speech free speech a lot of people
ask me i don't know about you click on
my dm he's like yo
what what what or when i meet them it's
like y'all i'm gonna start do commentary
what are some of the uh
keys and points that you could tell me
in order to succeed and this and that
and i often tell them you don't do your
thing and you didn't eventually you're
going to get better at it let me add
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't be [ __ ] lazy
don't be l three healthy what what why
don't
actual if you gotta comment on some [ __ ]
actually watch the [ __ ] that you're
gonna comment about
that that's the that's the first [ __ ]
listening you gotta watch the [ __ ]
first but if you don't listen
watch
watch the [ __ ]
at least
if you didn't listen
but you watch i'm like he missed the
point but if you didn't even watch
you're pontificating you just talking a
whole bunch of [ __ ] my dude
you didn't even watch how lazy
do you got to be
to not that that's what commentary is
it's not just commenting on [ __ ] you
actually have to watch it
like you're talking about [ __ ] that
we're not even mentioning in the [ __ ]
video and you're making a case out of it
i don't know how disingenuous you is or
if you're doing that [ __ ] on purpose
you didn't even you didn't even watch
all right wow
these guys are trying to be enlightened
[ __ ] you need to start by
turning on the [ __ ] light song
cause [ __ ] you in the dark and you
shooting we trying to be and you missed
you don't even watch no you shoot and
you miss you talking about we're not
even in the room who are you shooting at
this [ __ ] just shooting like
this
they live right here
what are you doing my guy at least at
least turn your head and watch where
you're shooting hey listen i think
you've been hanging out with his song
too much because you start sounding like
his dumb ass talk about i didn't even
watch these guys were they talking about
me i think they're transphobic
you sound just like him
free speech is a more broad
philosophical idea rather than
the type of free speech that's actually
enshrined by law well i'd like to know
what abba and preach think if the kkk
had a had a youtube channel one of them
one of them was just
you this guy really thinks it's a gotcha
wait wait these guys these guys these
guys are black
let's rebut them oh the the ku klux klan
you want to know the truth and this is
something that black people echo
you know what black people are really
tired of
we're tired of
innuendo when it comes to racism
we're tired of like the subversive stuff
you know the stuff where people act
condescending to you and act like you as
a minority can't think for yourself so
let me the enlightened liberal tell you
what you should think
of that in a word in a word that you're
going to understand let me put that okay
because you don't understand the others
yeah you don't understand your concept
so let me use some that you a black
person would be able to understand right
you know that's what we're tired of
we're tired of others i grew up in a
different time where
black folks and white folks used to
fight each other all the time they used
to just say what they thought okay
and i'm not gonna lie i preferred that
time you wanna know why i preferred it
because it was straight up not because
racism was worse than because let me
tell you it wasn't
but you knew what the other person was
thinking it was straight up okay i don't
like you
okay i nowadays deal with a lot of this
like
patronizing very just like subtle kind
that i can't call out directly right
because there's no proof and so if i say
everybody gaslights me like no no it's
not there right i told you that story
right where i did a comedy show and the
woman kept heckling the show but the way
she was doing it my spidey senses was
tingling i'm like this girl is moving a
little weird and i think i know why but
i'm not going to say nothing and i did
it and the comedians were all watching
the back end right
mind you i have a good set i leave i'm
back there okay she comes out she starts
dropping n-bombs in front of me and all
the other queens i get excited you wanna
know why i get excited yeah cause you
could
that's you
[Laughter]
thank
[ __ ]
thank you and everybody because i was
thinking with that i got the evidence
now oh if you a [ __ ] up person i want
to be able to see it
so i can call it out
so i could go this is why i disagree
this is why you [ __ ] up
it's much more difficult nowadays to do
that because everyone's trying to toe
the line right and the more you guys put
up these barriers what ends up happening
is not that you silence this kind of
rhetoric it's not like you guys are
making things better that's not what's
happening you know what's happening
instead
people are becoming much more smarter
with the way that they do it
right they start to use coded language
to describe people they dislike
all of a sudden they're not they're
thugs
right they're this they're that they'll
find different words to make sure you
know what we talking about but i didn't
see it explicitly so i'm good me parsley
i prefer it out in the open oh that's
how you move be good because guess what
there's a white pursuit purposes on
youtube right now and they get to float
through this space without any issues i
don't know why because they just knew
what words to navigate so they don't get
any issues me parsley let it all out
let's see everybody's dirty laundry let
everybody say what the [ __ ] they
thinking so we know what it is and we
know what to avoid
people like andrew tate find out a woman
finds out oh this guy likes andrew tate
this guy i'm trying to date i'm gonna
stay away from because i know what
andrew tate says now you can avoid it
you can't avoid any more because guess
what now the same guy was watching
entertains gonna watch somebody who's a
little bit more coded with they [ __ ] but
holds the exact same [ __ ] views
you didn't make the world a better place
you didn't think things safer for
everybody you just made it easier for
problematic people to navigate the space
that's it that's all you did you're
giving out the codes basically that's
what you want that's it you're giving
out the you're you're they are the
ways you're the ways application for
them yep okay we can't do that we're
gonna do that instead
coffeezilla who oh look coffeezilla had
the pretty much exact same tate take as
us let's see coffeezilla said i dislike
tate but
but
kids are going to grow up thinking their
only weapon against stupid ideas is deep
platforming
bro my dude heard the exact same take as
us or what he thinks is the exact same
take he went well this one doesn't sound
so bad
well this one doesn't sound so bad it's
coming from coffeezilla not these
[ __ ] idiots
let let me be nuanced let me think about
this thing bro it's the same [ __ ]
thing you thought that we said in the
person behind us
why are you pondering all this and
nobody's saying [ __ ] oh all of a sudden
nobody
waking up [ __ ] crickets okay [ __ ]
crickets on the team okay what happened
to the rest of y'all all right all right
y'all what what time i'm not man hey you
know what i'm starting to see what
jedeon was saying about this liberal
races i'm starting to see it play this
[ __ ]
this just doesn't happen that often to
do platforming
huh
what the [ __ ] are you talking about the
platforming happens all the time
cancel culture is not this fake thing
there's people with menial jobs who lose
it because they said something on
twitter on instagram
oh geez it's about their life
that's not famous people no that's
everybody like everybody i know is on
the second account third account
ever a lot of people i know it's not
because they take some time it's mean
sometimes it's weak risky [ __ ] sometimes
it's just showing breastfeeding yeah
sometimes it's just showing art
sometimes is this what
are you high
or are you late
us
i'll say it in quebec or soul
and again this isn't misinfo this is a
violent hate group
are kids going to think that are guys
going to think that about when isis's
youth channel youtube channel got banned
what are these wild comparisons one can
say andrew tate is bad his ideas are
terrible and not compare him to [ __ ]
isis
or the ku klux klan like like honestly
it's almost insulting
it's almost insulting to black folks to
compare andrew tate to the
what are you smoking isis what are these
comparisons jesus
these people are making the most wild
analogies to make someone out to be back
and that's what they always do right
anytime someone's bad who are they right
they're the mustache man right they're
the the
[Applause]
can you guys not make an argument
against these ideas without comparing
them to the worst [ __ ] humans have
ever existed is that not possible
uh willian that's no surprise i mean
censorship in 4k
andrew tay has been banned
i don't agree with him but
banning people because they say stuff
you don't like is just straight soft you
mean like the kkk
[Music]
go [ __ ] yourself dude go [ __ ] yourself
you bucket hat [ __ ] [ __ ]
did you notice yo did you notice
i just want the audience to know
and this is why i would much rather that
all these like white supreme people had
their channels you wanna know why
because instead i wouldn't have to deal
with [ __ ] losers like l3l3 doing this
very like innuendo subversive type of
like belittling of black people right
because this [ __ ] is way more
infuriating
than what like someone called me the
n-word i'll be honest with you you want
to know why because this is patronizing
to a degree you cannot [ __ ]
understand in the art world i've dealt
with so many [ __ ] losers like this
guy who like i'm here to fight with
women i'm here to fight for [ __ ]
minorities these people have the worst
opinions in their heart of hearts about
these people they think they're too
[ __ ] dumb they just don't outwardly
say it they don't outwardly say it
look how every time it's a black person
well what if this was the ku klux klan
like we're too stupid to take ourselves
out of our own experiences and try to
understand other people
back in the day these [ __ ] just
said what they thinking
like listen yeah you know i love black
people and i want you guys to do well
but i don't think you guys can take care
of yourself so let me just do it for you
i wish they just come out and say that
[ __ ] you know what i mean just like
[ __ ] [ __ ] what his name is uh hassan
stupid ass uh
i didn't watch that you're only trans
son's relationship with the trans
community is interesting he once lost a
trans-related debate and people in his
community were rightfully upset with
them because they felt like he made them
look bad my issue as a trans person is
the fact that you a guy that isn't super
well versed on transition brought on a
known transport knowing he might bring
up transphobic [ __ ] you aren't exactly a
vashta trans debate fair point let's see
how humble his response is
i hope
i hope
that
the rest of your life is as horrible as
it is every single day okay there you go
suck my dick i want people to have a
better more positive approach to dealing
with issues i despise you i despise you
more than anything else on the planet
you are [ __ ] cancer that's my
ultimate goal and i feel like i achieved
that you are cancer in this community
and you're a cancer in every community
suck my dick for the past 15 months
you've been able to [ __ ] hide in
these ranks you cat boy [ __ ] you are
just a trans person sorry you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about what
the [ __ ] you're just a trans person that
was a mascot moment that was wild and
when the chance was [ __ ] when the
trans person came out and said oh this
is what you think i think you're doing
you're just
when that was that's a moment that was
the moment that's the moment that's the
moment oh
what these people